today i'm going to tell you about five
skills that you can put on your resume
that will make you more employable
okay so today i want to talk to you
about five skills that will put you
ahead of the pack when it comes to your
resume now these skills aren't
necessarily taught in college but it'll
help with the keyword search algorithms
that employers are using when they scan
your resume and you can learn the basics
of this stuff in roughly two or so weeks
now you know the deal like and subscribe
you're welcome to follow me on twitter
or connect with me on linkedin and if
you think there's something that needs
to be added to this list leave something
in the comments i'd like to hear what
you have to say now i'm mostly a
c-sharp.net guy but these skills are
pretty much universal no matter what
stack you choose now the first item is
sql and it really doesn't matter what
sql you choose you can choose microsoft
sql or mysql or postgresql it's pretty
much all the same across all different
kinds of relational databases with some
minor adjustments for each you want to
learn the basics of sql because these
days pretty much everything you do is
going to end up in a database somewhere
and odds are it's going to be a
relational database so the basics for
this would be crud operations learn how
to create read update and delete
records inside the database know what a
clustered and non-clustered index is and
know how to do a simple join now i'm not
saying to become a dba but if you know
how to create a web page take that
information from a web form and put it
into a database and then have another
page you read that information back out
of the database you are much more likely
to get a job than someone who doesn't
know how to do that the second skill is
jira now whenever i mention this the
seymours of the world are all like yeah
that's stupid here it's just a tool you
need it just let me explain seymour
so jira is basically a project tracking
tool um there's also pivotal tracker or
monday.com or tfs which i think now is
called azure devops it's just that right
now it seems like jira is the most
popular now jira is free for up to 10
users and it's really useful for
tracking your projects you can use it to
track your personal projects you can use
to track your school projects and you
can give out different accounts so
people are working with you on school
projects so you can track where you are
in completion of a project and once you
learn a little bit about jira you can
learn a little bit about the agile
development methodology if you don't
know anything about agile don't worry
about it i have a video on agile at the
end of this video now here's why jira is
important if you have jira and agile on
your resume i'm going to think
maybe this guy knows a little bit about
the software development life cycle and
that's a pretty important thing not to
have to teach someone when you're hiring
them so when it comes to jira know how
to create a sprint add tickets to a
sprint and move those tickets across the
board until they're complete the third
skill is get now getting github is so
useful because it's where most of the
world tends to keep their projects
source and version control is so
important to modern computer programming
that i don't know how we'd function
today without it yes if you're in
college doing personal projects you can
take your directories and zip them and
send them up to google drive as your
version control but i would suggest you
start practicing using git now now i've
been using git for years and even i
don't know everything about git honestly
i google a lot of stuff when i have to
do it so i don't expect you to know get
all that well but be able to create a
repository push something to that
repository pull something from that
repository i don't expect you to do
rebasing and merging yet but be able to
do simple tasks checking in and checking
out code the fourth thing you should
learn is aws or azure now i know what
you're thinking like aws and azure if
you combine the two there's like 400
services like
i know you don't have to learn every
single service my suggestion is on aws
or azure learn how to spin up a machine
create a pipeline to that machine and
deploy to that machine now this might be
pushing the boundary of learning
something in two weeks but it'll be very
useful because devops is only growing in
importance and knowing how to do this
can help get you a job as a junior
devops person the fifth skill is docker
now if you're running windows 10 home
you're not going to be able to run
docker so my suggestion is get something
like virtual box and run linux and then
you can install docker on linux in a
virtual machine create a small project
learn how to build a container deploy a
container and start and stop those
containers once you learn containers
you're going to wonder how the heck we
did anything before the advent of
containers and it's another bullet point
in your resume that's going to make
people take notice now if you're really
pressed for time can only learn one
thing my suggestion is to learn sql and
maybe if you have enough time learn a
little bit about git jira and docker are
really more like nice to haves aws and
azure are also nice to have but it may
be too difficult to learn that quickly
in order to pass an interview sql git
jira azure or aws and docker are the
five things that you can put in your
resume to make you stand out from the
crowd good luck on your next interview
[Music]